you're old and wise at this stage
so have you discovered meaning to this
whole thing why the hell are we
descendants of um
apes here on earth what's the meaning of
it what's the meaning of life i haven't
and and i i am income so the crazy so
the best learning
for me has been like no matter what
level of success you achieve
you're still worried about similar
things maybe on a slightly different
scale you're still concerned about the
same thing you're still self-conscious
about the same things just like
and
actually that moment going through that
is what makes you believe there's got to
be like more machinery to life or
purpose to life and that that we're all
chasing these materialistic things but
you start
start realizing like um it's almost like
you know the truman show when he gets
the edge and he like knocks against it
he's like what like there's this
awakening that happens when you get to
that edge that you realize oh
like sure it's great it's great that we
all chase money and fame and
and success
but you hit the edge and and i'm not
even claiming i hit an edge like like
elon's hit an edge like there's clearly
larger scales
but what's cool is you learn that like
it doesn't actually matter and that
there are all these other things that
truly matter
um that's not a case for working less
hard that's not a case for taking it
easy that's not a case for the four day
work we
what that is a case for is designing
your life exactly the way you want to
design it because
i don't know i i think we go around the
or you know the sun
a certain number of times and then we
die and then that's it that's me are you
afraid of that moment no not at all in
fact or at least not yet
listen i'm like a pilot like i do yeah
crazy things and i like
um no i like if anything i'm like oh
i gotta choose uh uh mindfully and
purposefully the thing i am doing right
now
and not just fall into it because you're
to wake up one day and ask yourself why
the hell you spent the last 10 years
doing x y or z yeah so i guess
my like shorter answer to this is
doing things on purpose
because you choose to do them
so important in life
and not just like floating down the
river of life hitting branches along the
way because you will hit branches right
but rather like literally plotting a
course and not having a 10-year plan but
just choosing every day to opt in
that i think has been more
like i haven't figured out the meaning
of life by any stretch of the
imagination but it certainly isn't money
and it certainly isn't fame and it
certainly isn't travel and it's like
and it's way more of like opting into
the game you love playing
every day opting in just opting in and
like it's don't let it happen you opt in
kevin uh it's great to end on the
love
and the meaning of life this is an
amazing conversation a lot of fun thank
you you gave me like a light into some
fascinating aspects of this of the
technical world and i can't honestly
wait
to see what you do next thank you so
much thanks for having me
you